Hi, I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and today
we're talking with John Mackey. He's the
co-founder and co-CEO of Whole Foods
market. John, thanks for talking to us.
Thanks for having me on, Nick.
This is a point in time where we have a presidential election between the two most
disliked and statist politicians in a generation at least. The economy is
slow, but is also kind of inventive.
You are a very high-profile libertarian. Is
this a good time to be a libertarian or
a bad time to be a libertarian? It's a
bad time to be a libertarian in the
sense that the left appears to be
increasingly trying to police correct
thinking, correct speech, and they
tend to go after those who do not you
know whether it be on climate change or
on gay marriage...it's a real chilling
effect for any kind of freedom of speech
and in that sense it's a bad time. It's a good
time in the sense that who knows what's
going to happen to the Republican Party.
They could suffer a melt down in this election and if that happens then possible
change within that party might be
possible...serious change for the first
time in a long, long time.
That could be a libertarian opportunity.
You were a supporter of Rand Paul in the election or in the Republican primary system
what do you think went wrong with his
candidacy?
I think several factors came into play. One is he was not seen... unlike his father who was seen as an
outsider...I don't think Rand was seen as
an outsider any longer. He was a senator.
He didn't...he thought he would get his
father's support and he didn't get it.
So I think that was the biggest
factor and then you had this...at a time
when terrorism is increasing the
message that we need to be less
aggressive militarily doesn't...is not
playing that well in mainstream
America who's scared. So that message did not land well. The security message was a
problem. And then I don't think his
economic message was...which I agreed with...
but I just don't think people are as that
interested in that right now.
So I think his timing might have been bad.
And then you have the whole populist
thing with the nativism movement that
Trump has capitalized on so much.
I think he was the outsider candidate and Rand Paul is the insider and just
one of many insiders and was rejected by
the electorate.
What is your thought on Trump? Is he...you know...is he
plausible in any way for you as a
candidate or as a president?
Uh, no. He's not.
You're a successful businessman. He is a successful businessman.
What do you sense is his kind of
philosophy of business or of commerce or of
economics and how does it differ from
yours?
I would say first of all he seems to me
to be almost a prototypical crony capitalist.
Meaning he's made donations to
both sides of the political party.
Oftentimes in real estate you need to
get certain approvals through various
government agencies and you got to be... you got to play both sides of the fence to
get deals done. He's a...I think Trump sees
himself primarily as a great deal maker.
And he wrote a book on it..."The Art of the Deal"...so he sees politics through that
spectrum, through that lens. And for him I
think he doesn't fit the kind of
entrepreneurial capitalist that I
feel like that I represent.
Non-cronyism, creating value for other people. And one of the interesting things of
course is that he is seen as a
capitalist. He's seen as a businessman.
And yet, in a lot of ways, he's not
really that well...a good representative of it.
Talk about Hillary Clinton because these are the choices, right? One of
them almost certainly is going to be the next President of the United States.
What do you worry about under a Hillary
Clinton presidency?
I mean there seems to be compelling evidence of the Clintons not being...
they're certainly not straight shooters. They seem to...Hillary seems to be...
as much as I complain about Trump being a crony capitalist, I think Hillary falls
into that category herself. I mean you
just look at the money she received from
all the speeches she's made and it's
like a who's who of the financial sector,
health care, and defense contractors. It's
astounding. And then you see the Clinton
Initiative with a lot of money pouring
in from foreign governments...
it's disturbing. I mean that doesn't...that's a
smoking gun it doesn't necessarily mean
that any bullets were fired, but it is
concerning to me to say the least.
Plus, we have the record of the Clinton
administration in the past
and you had all those pardons
granted at the end. It's...
it's disturbing. I worry about it.
But there is a third term out there at least..or a third
possibility which is Gary Johnson and Bill
Weld running as the Libertarian Party ticket.
What do you think of them?
I don't know Weld. I know Gary and yeah I like Gary.
Is he the perfect libertarian candidate?
No. But his overall...I probably agree with
him on about ninety percent of the stuff.
And that's far higher than I agree with
Hillary or Trump. So the interesting
thing there is they're polling pretty high.
But when people get in there to vote...
I mean I'm going to vote for Johnson so...
but when they get in there to vote
because the old argument...you're just throwing your vote away is such a powerful
argument that they're probably...he's
probably going to get fewer votes than
he's polling at the end of the day. But
still, I mean if the libertarians were
to get two or three percent that would
be an outstanding election cycle for
them because they've never gotten that
much before.
They're running in that kind of fat middle of where the country really is that people are
generally socially tolerant and fiscally
responsible. They want a government
that is less in your business and you
know and can pay its own bills.
Do you think that that kind of thinking is
actually ascendant? I mean clearly the
Republican and Democratic parties don't
give outlets to that kind of thinking, but
is America moving in that kind of
soft libertarian direction? I thought so when I read you
and Matt's
book a few years ago but it
doesn't seem to be playing out that way.
I mean the nativism that I had no
idea until Trump ascended how powerful
the nativism sentiments are because I
think that's the key to understand Trump.
It's nativistic in immigration,
nativistic in jobs, in foreign policy,
in taxes, and in every way it seems
very strong nativistic philosophy.
One of the interesting things and it hasn't
really come into play yet,
but polls routinely show that even
fifty percent or more of Republicans
believe in not just in current levels of
immigration, but a pathway to citizenship
or legality for currently illegals. And
Democrats it's a little bit higher.
So it will be interesting to see if
nativism...it clearly carried Trump
through the primary and then what
happens in a general election? Your
business in many ways is built on kind
of free trade agreements. The fact that
you can bring in goods from all over the
world and put them into one place.
Why does it...you know that a lot of
people are okay with on the right, but
then when you talk about bringing it...
letting people from all over the world
move here...
what is the switch that is
flipped that makes that a totally different
and much more terrifying scenario?
If you study history the United States and I've
studied it very carefully for a long
time
always when we're doing immigration
there's...whenever there's been
accelerated immigration in American history
there have been race riots and whether it be
the Irish coming in or Italians or there's
always been push back against it.
So it's like our nation can handle a certain
amount of immigration, but when it gets
to be too much too fast then the culture
is unable to absorb it effectively.
Americanize it so to speak. And people
become scared and threatened by it. And I
think we're in one of those situations
right now. Plus I think there is an
element of...probably element of racism
in it in the sense that
fear of non-whites and it's...
I think there's an element of that in it.
From your business perspective, what
are the biggest things holding back
economic growth? You know one of the
things over about the past 10 or 15 years...
average or economic growth has averaged
around two percent or less a year. The
historic average since World War II is
about three percent. So that's a big
variance.
It's a couple of obvious things.
Most importantly is regulations.
I feel like there's almost a regulatory
war against corporations in America
right now. It's the number of
regulators attacking Whole Foods is
unprecedented in our entire history. And
honestly, I don't feel like...it's risky
for me to even talk about it because I
don't want additional regulatory
harassment that cost our company tens of
millions of dollars. And I feel like
that's happening...I talked to other CEOs
and this is not just a Whole Foods
problem. They're all feeling the
squeeze on a...regulatory
agencies harassing them.
What's an example of a useless
regulation that you deal with that
you know it makes it harder to
deliver services and goods at a good price?
We're dealing with a toxic waste issue...
disposal of multiple vitamins that have
selenium in them. They have a little few micrograms and that's been classified by the EPA as
a toxic waste.
What is selenium?
Selenium is a trace mineral that we need nutritionally
but only in very small little amounts. So
when we're...what do we do
when multiple vitamins are returned to
us for some reason they're
dissatisfied. We take it back.
Well, because it has selenium in it we can't
just throw that in the landfill of which
of course we did. We just throw it in the trash. That now has to be disposed of as a toxic waste.
Well, I mean that sets up a whole toxic
waste disposal system for vitamins that
people are eating, okay? I would say
that seems like kind of a
nonsensical regulation. But there's all
types of employment regulations. Very...
it's increasingly difficult in the United States to be able to terminate anyone,
particularly anyone that's in a protected class. The amount of
paperwork that you have to track and
even then you're probably still going to
get sued and very likely you'll either
lose you'll have to settle.
To play devil's advocate people would
be like, "Well, it's good you shouldn't be
able to fire people quickly especially
people in protected classes because they're in
protected classes because they need
protection."
I disagree. I mean employment
is a voluntary exchange that occurs
between individuals who are looking for
work and employers are looking to hire. I
mean should people be able to quit
whenever they want to or should
we be able to force them to continue to
work for us?
I mean I firmly believe that it's not
in the best interest of any employer to
fire people arbitrarily. And this is
what's usually held up...abuse. And does
that occasionally occur?
Of course it does. That doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to set up
the system so that employers are
constantly being incented or harassed
if they do terminate someone. Because
again, why would they want to terminate a
good worker?
They wouldn't. And but yet they're
constantly seen as guilty of doing
something wrong and then they have to
prove their innocence when they
terminate someone. But that doesn't go on
the other side of the equation.
If somebody terminates or resigns because
they found a better job or they
don't like it or they're racist and they
don't like the company who knows.
But there's no...so it's to me a double
standard.
Talk about the 365 stores that
you're starting to roll out. How are
those different than a traditional Whole
Foods market and what are you hoping to
accomplish with them?
The stores are smaller than a traditional Whole Foods market. They have only about a quarter of
the other number of products that you
might have a Whole Foods. It's a very
curated product mix. And then we are
building these stores for about a third
of the cost of a regular Whole Foods
market. So the capital cost is
significantly lower. And then we've restructured
the stores to have far lower labor
component. The long and the short of it is
is that we've taken about a...what we call basis points a thousand basis points or ten
whole percentage points out of the cost
structure and that's been passed on to
the customers in much lower prices. So a
very low produce prices and very low
center store prices and then we get...we
have Whole Foods market's kind of
prepared foods selection and our quality
standards are still in effect. So we
think this is a very successful format
that we're probably going to have
hundreds of these stores within
not that many years.
And will they compete against Whole Foods market or do they supplement it or how does that work?
There will be some competition of course,
there'll be some overlap in customers. But what
we found so far is the cannibalization
has been less than we anticipated. That
we're getting a customer in that's more
price-sensitive that we were not getting
into Whole Foods market stores. And so
the number of Trader Joes bags that
we've seen shopping in our stores is
unprecedented.
Is that kind of the direct competitor for the (crosstalk)
I mean in some ways 365 competes with
Trader Joes. It competes with Sprouts
farmers markets. But of course the main
competitors are the mainstream
supermarkets like Kroger and HEB and
Wegmans. But we now have a model...a
business model that allows us to be less
expensive and not be under sold by
anyone. And that's a good place to be in
Speaking of cannibalization, let's talk
about the movie that you've helped
produce "At the Fork" which is done by the...
Lisa and John Papola...the great
documentary filmmakers. And it is about
John's kind of move towards veganism or
understanding of animal welfare in the
food production change.
Well of course John has now become a vegan. John Papola and Lisa Versaci
are married couple and they are...
Lisa is a vegetarian. John is a carnivore.
And the film starts out with at a Papola
family gathering where they're eating ribs.
It's called..is it the ribfest? Or meat feast? (crosstalk) yeah.
And that shows that. And then Lisa expresses her disapproval of that and they begin this journey
into America basically to see how our animal foods are raised. And what's fascinating about the
film is the film itself is very
non-judgmental and lets the camera do
the talking and it lets every...so it goes
from some of the factory farm producers
all the way up to some smaller animal
ranchers who are treating their animals
surprisingly very, very well high. So
they're all different grades of welfare treatment.
And each in a sense allows
each of the animal farmers or ranchers
to give their own philosophy.
I mean it's actually...really I found it fascinating
because it's a movie...it is about
a journey and there aren't villains here
or the farmers...the factory
farmers aren't treated as poor stupid
people who only care about a buck. But
they do have constraints and they
voice time and time again like I will treat my livestock anyway
that my customers ask me to.
It is fascinating because their
philosophies get articulated and so the
film is remarkably fair. It's unlike some
films might come in with a a real biased
point of view and then set it...say if
Michael Moore was producing a documentary
he would he would come in with a bias and
then make sure the film comes out that way.
This was a discovery process and
they let these far- they're fair to all the
farmers. They all get a chance
to get their philosophical perspective.
Are there farmers...because I was taken by
the you know at various stages as they get closer to
a more kind of animal friendly
generally a higher-end price point and stuff like that.
But all of the producers pretty much say some variation of I don't really
have a stake in how I
raise my...like what I'm doing is to serve the
customer and if the customer
wants something at a certain price
I'm going to do it in a more industrial
way or less industrial way.
Are there people who are ideologically
committed to kind of factory farm
processes or you know treating livestock
in the least thoughtful way?
I don't know if ideology is what I would say... the overwhelming driving thing has
always been in food production is how
can we get costs down? Just like Whole
Foods market with 365 is thinking
through our business model how can we
take cost out so we can get lower
prices to our customers? That same logic
carries for...that's why capitalism
works. And here you have is one of the...
James McWilliams says...a professor of
history...says these decisions that moved
us towards the factory farm system were
hundreds, if not thousands of small
little innovations that took us in this
direction of taking costs out of the system.
And ultimately the lowest cost
system is one that has scale and which
minimizes feed inputs and all the
other factors of production. And that
tends to be by most dispassionate
viewers is pretty inhumane. Pretty cruel to the animals...
You are a vegan yourself?
Correct.
Can you briefly recount your conversion?
A little over 13 years ago I was at an annual
Whole Foods market annual meeting
for our stockholders in Santa Monica, CA.
We were being picketed by
animal rights activists and they were
disrupting our meeting. I wasn't very happy
about that. I thought like they don't...
they shouldn't even be here. This is
inappropriate. But I got into a discussion
with the activists after the
meeting was over. In particular this one
very tiny but passionate young woman
named Lauren Ornelas and we began an
email exchange and we were going back
and forth because for my attitude back
then was I don't know why they're
picking on us. We're doing more for
animals than anybody else. Why aren't they going after Safeway or Kroger for example.
And because...as they would say, "Well we
thought you would actually listen.
We didn't think they would." And I remember her telling me she said, "John, I can see
that you're actually a very idealistic man. You're not like I thought you would be
I didn't think...you're not a typical
corporate CEO. But when it comes to
animal welfare and the way animal
livestock animals are treated in the United States
you are remarkably ignorant." And...
Was she right about that?
Yes. And you shouldn't be because you're
running a fairly large corporation and
you sort of owe it to all of your
customers and employees to know better
about these things. So I was taken aback
and I realize you know she's probably
right about that. I could be better
informed. So that summer...summer of
2003 I read about a dozen books on
livestock animals in America.
How it evolved, practices. And God about midway through after I read four or five books I thought
you know she's really right. I don't know...I
didn't know anything and furthermore we
gotta change and do something about it.
By the time the summer was over I said,
"I'm not going to eat animals anymore."
I became a vegan and from
an ethical standpoint and then also decided
you know Whole Foods needs to do a lot
more here. So we invited the activists to
work with us as...on our team so to
speak and then bring in animal
scientists, bring in the farmers
themselves. Bring them together into
meetings and let's talk about how we can
develop more higher animal welfare
systems that have higher...and so
that's how I converted and that's what
Whole Foods has been doing ever since.
Is there a point where the you know
where you will from a kind of moral
perspective stop selling animal products
or like how do you square that
between you're treating the animals
better but you're still selling them.
Is that because the customer wants them or where when does that...
You know it's funny. I get asked that question a lot.
And I suppose because I'm so closely
identified with the Whole Foods market
brand and people for the most part
don't understand how corporations work
they think, quite incorrectly, that Whole
Foods market is like my company.
That I'm like this all-powerful owner,
that can do whatever I want. But in
fact, I founded the company, but we're a
very large corporation at this point and
it...I always tell the story that let's
say I wanted to do that. I would not be
able to do it. If I said, "You know what
guys? I really think we need to stop
selling meat. That's just the right thing
to do. And so effective this date I'm
issuing a command as the as co-founder,
co-CEO that we're going to phase out of meat."
Well everybody would think it was a joke. They would laugh and
I'd say, "No, no. I'm very serious about
this. I have seen the light. We are going
to stop selling meat at Whole Foods
market." And they would say, "John, you've
got to be kidding. You know we can't do
that. It would completely ruin the business."
I say, "Nevertheless, it's the right thing to
do and by God we're going to do it."
About that time of course the rest of the
executive team would be like, "What is
happening? John is like going crazy." But
then if I persisted calls would go to the
board of directors and say, "We got to do
something. He's about to wreck our business."
And I would get calls from the board and
they would say, "John, you know you can...
you can't do this. You're going to have to
back off on this." And I'd say, "No, this is right
thing to do by God I'm gonna do it." Well
if I continue to persist I would be
removed as a CEO. That's just the reality
of the situation. That's the way business sort of works.
And that's the right thing for them to do because Whole Foods market ultimately...
ultimately has to serve its customers. And I'd like nothing
better than the customers to
vote with their dollars for Whole Foods market
to stop selling animal foods. But until that vote occurs
we're going to continue to sell them
because that's what they want to buy.
And that's part of the function of "At the
Fork", right? That...I mean you're...it's not a
preachey movie. I mean it is didactic,
there's a message there, but it's
hopefully raising people's consciousness.
I really think that "At the Fork"... if it has a purpose...its to raise people's
consciousness
because the average American has
no idea how animals are
raised. They don't want to know. There's
sort of massive cultural denial about it.
I actually think that a hundred years from now
we'll look back on the factory farm
era with the same kind of ethical
revulsion that we look back on
say slavery. Which was obviously completely morally reprehensible by any standard.
And I think this will be seen in a
similar light. Although when I say that
sometimes people are offended because
they don't...they see the moral
revulsion of slavery but they have not yet
opened their eyes to see the moral
reversion what we're doing to factory
farm animals. So this film is an attempt to...
it's PG-13. We're not showing the
most horrible stuff because otherwise
people just walk out of the theater.
We're giving it in a measured dose and
most importantly we're showing them that
there are better alternatives. So if I
had my way when people finish watching
that film they, they'd be faced with an
ethical dilemma which is I'm going to
either I'm not going to eat meat anymore
or I'm only going to eat higher animal welfare meat.
And that would be the choice I'd like to see
people make.
Well the movie is "At the Fork" and we have been talking
to Whole Foods co-founder and co-CEO John Mackey.
Thanks so much for talking to us, John.
Thanks, Nick.
For Reason TV, I'm Nick Gillespie.